ALEX MAIER: Hello and welcome
to the special episode of Women
Techmakers.
My name is Alex Meier, and
I'm the community manager
at Google Cloud Platform.
Today with me are Karen
Sandler, the executive director
of the GNOME Foundation.
Hello Karen.
KAREN SANDLER: Hi,
Alex, how's it going?
ALEX MAIER: Pretty good.
KAREN SANDLER: I'm so
excited to be here,
and I'm so excited to talk about
the outreach program for women.
Thank you.
ALEX MAIER: Absolutely.
Happy to have you on the show.
My second guest today is
Marina Zhurakhinskaya,
who is the community
lead at Red Hat.
How are you doing, Marina?
MARINA ZHURAKHINSKAYA: Yes, hi.
I'm doing well.
Very excited to be on
the program as well.
ALEX MAIER: Wonderful.
As you mentioned
earlier, we are here
to talk about the women
outreach program at GNOME.
Marina, can you tell us
a little bit about it?
MARINA ZHURAKHINSKAYA: The
very first precursory program
was the Women's Summer
Outreach program
that was done by the
GNOME Foundation in 2006.
And the reason we
did that was we
participated in Google Summer
of Code, the great opportunity
that Google has for
students to have
paid remote internships working
with a mentor on an open source
project.
And we participated
in that program
since 2005, when it started.
And in 2006 we had 180
applicants, and none of them
appeared to be women.
So, that was the first time
when Hanna Wallach and Chis
Ball put together a two-month
program very similar
to Google Summer of Code.
And when they put this
call out, they in fact
had 100 applicants
for the program.
And over the next
few years we noticed
that that did not actually
leave a lasting impact
on our communities.
In 2009, when I was one of the
eight women at the conference,
and one of the
four women who were
software developers
for the project,
from among about
1,000 contributors,
and we still had maybe one or no
women in Google Summer of Code
this year, we decided to
kind of reinvent the program
and start over in
the internships.
KAREN SANDLER: How long has
the program been in existence?
MARINA ZHURAKHINSKAYA:
Since 2010, and we
have had 130 participants.
We do two rounds
per year, because we
have to catch up so much.
And we are noticing that
there are advantages
to both doing a May through
August round and a December
to March round.
In particular, December
to March round appeals
to students in the
Southern Hemisphere.
But two main differences
from Google Summer of Code
is that we are actually open
to non-students as well,
and a big part of our
participants are not students,
and also we have non-coding
tasks in addition
to coding tasks.
ALEX MAIER: Oh, that's great.
Karen, what is GNOME
Foundation's role
in all of this?
KAREN SANDLER: The
GNOME Foundation
organized the program.
When we originally
founded the program,
it was for the GNOME project.
And we found that the
program had such a big impact
on our project, it was bringing
so many extraordinary women,
we went from having,
as Marina said,
4% women at our annual
conference, which
is called GUADEC, to this
year we recently had 18%,
which is often a statistic
given as the number of women
in proprietary software.
And the gap between
free software
and proprietary
software was very
wide in terms of how many
women were participating,
which was really surprising.
We've had this major
change in GNOME,
and because it was
so good for GNOME,
we decided we couldn't
keep it to ourselves.
What we did was we opened
it up to other free software
projects, who also were
interested in trying
to help solve this problem.
We now have over 20
projects participating
in the outreach program for
women, including the Linux
kernel, and Mozilla,
and Wikimedia-- a lot
of great organizations.
We have both Debian and Fedora.
It's pretty fun.
And different
projects participate
during different rounds,
and GNOME Foundation
serves as the overall
organizer for the project.
As Googlers know,
the Summer of Code
is a massive and
inspirational program.
It's amazing.
I honestly have no idea
how Google handles it.
It's such a big and
amazing project.
But for us, having
this smaller program
where-- in this
particular round--
we have around 30
participants, it's
a lot for a small nonprofit
organization to handle.
But we do so for all
of the free software
projects participating, and
I think it works out well.
ALEX MAIER: This is great.
So have you experienced
any growth since 2010
in the number of participants?
Are you trying to
keep it steady?
MARINA ZHURAKHINSKAYA:
Absolutely.
We started with about 10
participants each round,
was a GNOME project.
And then when Karen stepped
in as executive director,
she suggested that we
expand the program.
At first we did a pilot
round, expanding the program
to just one project, which
was the twisted project,
was a Software
Freedom Conservancy.
And as any programmer
knows, expanding one to two
is almost as hard as
expanding as two to many.
So, that was the
first step, and then
after that when we
expanded to having
about 10 participating
organizations in each round,
we have had about
30 participants
in each round for the
last three rounds.
ALEX MAIER: This is great.
What kind of tasks
can women expect
when they participate
in your program?
What can they choose from?
KAREN SANDLER: There's
really a wide variety
of tasks or projects
that women can
work on when they join the
Outreach Program for Women.
As Marina was saying, one
of the key differences
between Outreach Program for
Women and Google Summer of Code
is that our program welcomes
women to do other things that
are non-coding tasks, which is
really valuable for attracting
women to free software.
So, for example, we have
marketing internships
and design internships
and things like that.
I think it's several things.
One, is that it's
an acknowledgement
that free software, and
software in general,
needs so much more than
just coding and valuing
contributions in those
fields it's really important.
Another thing is
that sometimes women
who are interested
in coding find
it a little more
accessible to come
in in some of those
other projects.
I, for example, had an intern
who I was the mentor for,
who did marketing, and she
had such a good experience
with her Outreach
Program for Women
that she took coding
classes and she
participated in Summer of Code.
So we have some of
that happening as well.
I think it's twofold.
It's valuing the non-coding
side of free software
and also recognizing
that helping women build
relationships
within our community
is also really valuable.
ALEX MAIER: How
would a woman who
wanted to participate in
this program be able to join?
What does she need to
do and what can she
expect when she first
establishes contact?
MARINA ZHURAKHINSKAYA:
What we require
of all participating
organizations
is to have a list
of mentors who are
available at any time
throughout the year,
for the prospective participants
to approach and to work
with informally on
contributing to the project.
A very strong
requirement that we
have for the program
for the applicants
is that they need to make
a relevant contribution
during their application
process and offer
the informal mentorship
and help during that time.
Just going over the
available organizations
and available projects
and contacting a mentor
and just following
the guidelines
from the organization
about how to get started,
and actually getting
started, diving in
is the best recipe
for planning to apply.
KAREN SANDLER: I love
this part of the program
because it basically
assists all applicants
in getting involved in
free software projects.
We have to be very selective.
We don't have funding
for a lot of spots.
And so it's very hard to
always choose the women
that we wind up selecting.
But all of the women who
apply have the opportunity
to work with a mentor
and have the opportunity
to become a contributor to a
free and open source project.
Just the application process
alone is really valuable
to go through.
We do find that women who
go through the process
sometimes, even
if they didn't get
the internship during the time
that they applied, if they
stuck around and
continued to contribute,
they become a much stronger
candidate for the next round.
Even though we get many more
applicants than we can accept,
every woman who
completes an application
has become a contributor to a
free and open source software
project.
I think that's pretty cool.
MARINA ZHURAKHINSKAYA: I've
seen a lot of our participants
describe this first
contribution as something
that got them hooked,
that showed to them how
addictive contributing
to free software
is, because it's a thrill to
be able to see changes go out
and be publicly available
and be making a difference
in a project that's available to
anybody and can help somebody,
and a lot of people are
using it around the world.
A lot of people have
described it as addictive.
I'd also like to mention
another requirement
that we have for our interns
is to blog every two weeks.
The blogs have been aggregated
on the Women in Free Software
planet, and that's an amazing
boost to read that planet
and to see what they are doing
during their internships.
It also gives them visibility.
ALEX MAIER: Is there
a website that women
who are interested
in your program
can visit and learn more
and maybe participate?
KAREN SANDLER: Absolutely.
You should go to gnome.org/opw.
You'll find information about
our program, how to apply,
what participating
organizations there are,
and who is participating now.
ALEX MAIER: And when is
the next round opening?
MARINA ZHURAKHINSKAYA:
The application deadline
is very similar in time
to Google Summer of Code.
For Outreach for
Women, it's March 19.
For Google Summer of
Code it's March 21.
What we do for our May
through August round
is that we parallel the dates
for Google Summer of Code,
because part of
what we like to do
is kind of going back to
the original motivation.
For the program, we want
to encourage more women who
are students, who
are coders to apply
for Google Summer of Code.
That's part of what we
do with the program.
So for example, last summer
10% of the participants
in the Summer of
Code were women,
and the organizations
that also participated
in Outreach Program
for Women had 14% women
amongst their participants
in Google Summer of Code.
KAREN SANDLER: One
great example of that
is that Wikimedia
media, for example.
In all of the years
of participating
in Summer of Code, they had
only ever had one applicant.
After participating in one
round of Summer of Code
they had seven female
participants in Summer of Code.
So the program has
been really working.
It's amazing.
ALEX MAIER: This is great.
The numbers, the percentages
that you're naming
are absolutely not
typical in the industry,
and particularly in the
open source project.
So great kudos for
you for running this.
KAREN SANDLER: Google has
been a really strong sponsor
since the beginning
of the program.
Aside from just providing
the model of Summer
of Code, and the fact that
the two programs really
work together,
Google sponsorship
has been really important.
ALEX MAIER: Thank you.
MARINA ZHURAKHINSKAYA:
Absolutely.
ALEX MAIER: Well, thank
you very much for coming
on the program,
Karen and Marina.
I'm looking forward to
welcoming you back on the show
again sometime.
Thank you very
much for watching.
My name is Alex Meier, and
this is Women Techmakers.